speakers today we are pleased to have
will perkins
who has the record of having random
twice in the
title something from the random cluster
model at all temperature on random
graphs
please okay thank you and thanks for
inviting me this workshop has been
really nice the talks but also uh seeing
everyone
um i'm gonna do something worse than use
random twice in my
talk uh twice in the title i'm gonna use
the word cluster to mean
two completely different things um so
beware of that
uh but this this will be joint work with
tyler helmuth and matthew jensen
uh both in england okay so one question
i think a lot of us are interested in
is when are phase transitions in physics
models
barriers to algorithms so i want to talk
a little bit about that
i want to tell you today maybe a problem
you have heard about or maybe haven't
there's a big open problem in the field
of approximate counting
a sharp bis bipartite independent set
and so specifically i want to know our
phase transitions for
these dishard problems on random graphs
actually barriers to efficient
algorithms and what are we gonna do so
um
and it's very a good audience for this
talk i hope
is we're gonna take some classical
techniques from statistical physics
um and use them for algorithms and for
deriving probabilistic information
these techniques are i guess are much
older than things derived from the
cavity method but i think they
complement them nicely
and you know the reason i got interested
in statistical physics in the first
place was
by meeting people through computer
science that are here so like chris
uh chris moore blenca and florent and
the more i learn about the statistical
physics the more i like it
um and so that's somehow the background
for this uh work
um like the last talk uh i'll show you
that if you take an algorithmic approach
sometimes this helps
us prove new probabilistic results and
in particular
uh i'm hoping i can tell you the answer
to the following question what exactly
happens
at the critical temperature for the pots
model on a random regular graph
okay so the the model i'll talk about is
the pots model
we are picking an assignment of q colors
to the vertices of some graph
with probability proportional to e to
the beta times the number of
monochromatic edges
okay and here for my talk uh i really
will be working in one of these easier
models
uh i'll be talking solely about the
ferromagnetic case so ferromagnetic pots
model
the monochromatic edges are preferred
and the inverse temperature this is the
parameter that controls the interaction
strength
of course we have this normalizing
constant the partition function
and understanding this will be a crucial
task
eventually i'll shift to the random
cluster model and what is this this is a
probability distribution on edge subsets
of some graph
and the probability pick a particular
subset of edges
is proportional to e to the beta minus
one to the number of edges
times q to the number of connected
components uh
formed with the vertex set and that edge
subset so it's a it's a tilted
bond percolation model and
again it has its own partition function
and in this case there's unlike the pots
model where there's q
maximum weight configurations here we
have two possible maximum weight
configurations the disordered state the
no edges
and the ordered ground state all edges
uh
taken and and to emphasize uh the pots
model of course q needs to be an integer
but random cluster model
q can be any positive real
okay and so the way i've defined things
actually
when q is an integer the pots model
partition function equals
the random cluster partition function
and there's this nice coupling
which you may have heard of uh let's say
you're given a random cluster
configuration so that's
this random subset of edges of this
graph in blue
what do you do to get a pots
configuration you find the connected
components okay so here's a connected
component
here's a connected component uh the
isolated vertices are connected
components
and so on and then what you do is you
flip a one over q
uh coin independently for each connected
component
and color them with one of the colors
and in this way you end up with
a configuration drawn according to the
pots model
uh so so the bottom line is if you can
understand the random cluster model
uh it's a bit more general but you also
uh can understand the pots model in
terms of counting
sampling phase transitions and so on
so leslie goldberg talked about
approximate counting on monday
just to remind you what the major the
main tasks are the approximate counting
problem is to
find a multiplicative approximation to
the partition function
so given epsilon you want to find a one
plus or minus epsilon
multiplicative approximation to the
partition function
and you want this algorithm that you
have to run in time polynomial
and the number of vertices of your graph
and one over epsilon
if you can do this deterministically
this is an fptas
if you need randomness as an fp ras
the approximate sampling problem on the
other hand is uh to output a sample from
uh a configuration with a distribution
close and total variation distance
uh to the true distribution
okay and the and uh there's some main
approaches to both of these problems
there's
markup chains uh we saw in the last talk
there's the method of correlation decay
so the the whites method
there's barvanac's polynomial
interpolation method
based on the zeros of the partition
function in the complex plane
and then what i'll talk to you about
today is related to that method but it's
using the cluster expansion
from statistical physics
okay so some some general comments on
approximate counting and sampling so for
some models we know
actually that these problems uh can be
np-hard uh for
some ranges of parameters and some
classic graphs so hardcore
the hardcore model this is the result uh
well alan sly proved the tight results
matching the whites bound
uh same with anti-ferromagnetic easing
or pots
and for these problems i i suppose it's
not so uh
hard to believe it's mp hard because
even finding a ground state
is mp heart so finding the maximum
independent set of a graph or finding a
proper coloring
these these are already mp heart
problems
and then on the the other extreme we
have some problems where approximate
counting and sampling is tractable on
all graphs
and so this is like the germ sinclair
ferromagnetic easing approximation
algorithm
or the monomer dimer model this is
matchings in a graph these are easy on
all graphs
but the the problems i'm going to talk
about today lie in the middle
and these problems have been proved to
be
as hard to approximate as approximating
the number of independent sets in a
bipartite graph
so this is the class sharp bis defined
by dyer goldberg green hill and gerum
and that includes ferromagnetic pots so
colorings and bipartite graphs
stable matchings approximate uh counting
and sampling these
so what sort of characterizes these
problems is that finding a ground state
we know how to do in polynomial time
it's easy to find a maximum weight
independence a maximum size independent
set in a bipartite graph
or find a ground state of the
ferromagnetic pots model
but we don't know about approximate
counting and sampling we don't know it's
hard and be hard and we don't have a
polynomial time algorithm
so this is a great like middle ground of
problems
to try to understand
okay and so what's the connection with
random graphs so
on one hand random graphs we can use to
show some kind of hardness so perhaps
uh slow mixing for markup chains we know
how to show
slow mixing for global dynamics for pots
for some
graphs like lattices complete graphs
random graphs
so that at least we can use random
graphs to show that certain algorithms
don't work
these mp hardness proofs for
anti-ferromagnetic
two-spin systems come via reduction so
sly and then the follow-up work
this uses phase coexistence results for
say hardcore on random
bipartite graphs so even though we don't
know that uh
hardcore on bipartite graphs is hard at
all
these are used as gadgets in a bigger
construction to show mp hardness for
non-bipartite
graphs and similarly these bis
hardness reductions come become
using gadgets that are random graphs so
maybe
plot's model on a random d regular graph
is used as a gadget to show
the best hardness of pots on bounded
degree graphs
in in this paper so this is this is a
connection
um but of course you know one theme of
this workshop is that random graphs also
often provide the candidate hard
instances
and this is a very different question
and
it's not clear at all to me what are the
candidate hard instances for these
dishard problems and you could ask of
course are
random graphs hard instances for bis
and i want to give you at least one
example today where the answer is no
these are not hard instances
and please please do stop me with
questions as you go on i'll try to
listen or monitor the chat
great okay so what's our result our
result is
for d at least five and q large enough
as a function of d
we have efficient counting and sampling
algorithms for the pots and random
cluster models
on random d regular graphs at all
temperatures so
this is subcritical supercritical and
the critical temperature
so in this case uh at least if if you
let q be large enough as a function of d
uh these are not hard instances and you
can sample and count
in the presence of the phase transition
well this is this is all non-negative
beta in other words you're sticking to
fair magnetic
yes so for the whole talk this will be
the the easy case the fair magnetic case
in particular that's that's the case
where you have this coupling with random
cluster model
uh it's also the case where you know the
number of ground states is bounded
and so we're not in some glassy uh hard
region so this is really
uh i'm talking about easier problems
than a lot of this workshop but
hopefully we can say different things
about it
um and if you want to know how large q
is it should be at least like
d to the d so that's pretty large
there's no tower involved
okay and then i i promise that you can
also derive some probabilistic results
uh from the methods and so our
probabilistic results say for the random
cluster model
uh are that there is some critical beta
as a function of q and d
um if you're not at critical then this
the free energy is analytic
and the the gibbs measure exhibits real
exponential decay of correlations
so the correlation between two edges and
the random cluster model decays
exponentially in their distance
and then we can also prove some results
about local weak convergence
so the gibbs measure if you like pick a
random configuration from your
model pick a random vertex and look at
the depth t neighborhood
what you see the the the edges the
distribution of
edges that you see converges locally to
either the
free free measure or the wired measure
on the infinite tree
uh for beta less than beta c and beta
greater than beta c respectively
so this is called local weak convergence
and then we can say a lot at critical so
at critical we actually can say
what is the distribution of the ordered
and disordered states
um this is this converges to some random
variable and it's
uh written in terms of a sum of weighted
plus on random variables which
correspond to small cycle counts
perhaps not surprisingly and and also
the
local weak convergence also holds so we
have a mixture of
free and wired at the critical point and
so essentially anything as
long as you let q be large you can
deduce any probabilistic
information basically that you would
want to know
okay so previous results for pots and
these results were obtained either with
uh you know uh
rigorous uh applications or
implementations of like the cavity
method
or by a second moment method and so in
particular the golanis the fenkovic
pagoda yang paper
and a nice paper of dembo montanari sly
and sun
there's a formula in in fact for the
potts case for beta critical
and uh the dembo montenarie slide in
sandpaper actually
is working in a more general setting
than just random regular graphs
so some locally tree-like graphs uh and
we know that's the
the phase transition um the there's a
formula for the free energy
it's given by the beta formula uh and
this
uh gallinus paper uh gives a weak form
of
phase coexistence at beta critical so uh
the ordered and disordered or the the q
ordered states and the one disordered
state in the pots model
each have at least inverse polynomial
probability
um and this is enough to obtain things
like slow mixing of swenson wang
and uh to give these gadgets for the
this hardness
so yeah so so i what i think is
interesting is how these
the different the methods we use are
very very different but they complement
these results
so for example we have no idea how to
get a formula for beta critical
but we can get maybe more detailed
probabilistic information
and this notion of local weak
convergence i don't think something like
this was known for pots at all before
but this was known for easing
uh by dembo montanari and montemar
montanari mosul sly
and something like that just finding the
distribution of the log
log partition function unnormalized
and finding actually the distribution uh
and the connection to small subgraphs
and
small cycle counts this appears in some
papers amin code
oakland has uh but this is in in harder
models but below the condensation
threshold
and here we can deduce this distribution
in the easier model
but at all temperatures
okay so uh what about algorithms so
algorithms
there was some stuff known at high
temperature so within the uniqueness
regime
which is actually below the critical
regime so this is the tree uniqueness
regime
there was an efficient algorithm at low
enough temperatures for pots
i had a paper with matthew jensen and
peter kibash where we could sample
at sufficiently low temperatures uh but
really
that what inspired this paper was a
paper about zd
that i had recently with uh borgx chase
helmuth and teddily
where we on zd we could get efficient
sampling and counting algorithms for
large q
and all temperatures and again by sort
of
uh algorithmizing this these classical
techniques from statistical physics
uh and the these algorithms are based on
uh yeah polymer models and cluster
expansion which i'll
i'll say maybe one minute about in this
talk
okay so uh what are the techniques so
as i said we aim to apply the techniques
that people have used
to study the pots model on lattices but
we want to try to apply them to random
graphs
there's a there's a complication in that
we the
zd has quite a lot of geometry you can
talk about interiors
exteriors you can use topology and you
have transitivity
um and we lose that but we we try to
make up for this with the great
expansion that a random a random graph
has
and so while in the lattice you need to
use contour models and separate regions
by contours
here we can use the simpler polymer
models um
but uh the i guess the tricky technical
thing is we have to deal with the
non-local
random cluster interaction this q to the
number of connected components
okay so the three steps that i'll
describe the first is a fairly easy and
let's just use expansion properties
to show that when q is large then with
very high probability on an expander
if you pick a sample from the random
cluster model you'll either see
nearly all the edges so more than 90 of
the edges
or at most 10 of the edges so there's
no middle ground and then if you write
your partition function as the sum over
few few edges many edges and in between
you can basically ignore the in-between
and focus on approximating
these two partition functions
okay so how will we do this we're going
to use these polymer models and cluster
expansions we want to rewrite the
partition function say
z dis the one of configurations close to
the empty set
as a sum over collections of some
disjoint geometric objects
polymers and a product of these weights
of polymers
and the idea of the cluster expansion is
if the weights decay fast enough as a
function of size
then the cluster expansion which is a
power series for the log partition
function
uh will converge and so what do we have
to show we have to show that
we can express the partition function in
a way that the weights factorize
and uh decay the polymer weights decay
uh okay very good so i'll i'll show you
just with a picture what we do
so from the disordered state we're
trying to
understand deviations from the empty set
of edges
so we'll see a sprinkling of edges and
here polymers will just be connected
components
of occupied edges okay
and the weight of a polymer while you
lose some connected components right
these three vertices used to all be in
separate connecting components from the
empty set
but now they're in one so you lose some
weight of connected components but you
gain some weight
uh for having the edges and it turns out
expansion is enough to show that these
weights decay
enough to converge that's on one hand
on the other hand we want to talk about
deviations from the ordered
configuration so the all
occupied configuration and so your first
attempt would set would be to say that
well i want to look at
connected components of unoccupied edges
and have those be my polymers there's a
there's a problem though
which is that the weights don't
factorize so here we have
these connected components of unoccupied
edges
each of which on its own uh don't
disconnect the root from the rest of the
graph but all together they do
and so you change the number of
connected components um
you know based on uh a multi-body
interaction instead of
just a product of weights so we have to
get around that and that's really like
the the main idea to make all this work
so
here are the red edges the the solid red
edges are unoccupied edges
and what we do is we inductively create
something we call the boundary
and we look at a vertex and say well if
if at that vertex
uh most of your edges are in the
boundary already
then add all your edges so we add this
dotted edge
and we do this inductively so starting
from this configuration of unoccupied
edges i would have added all the
dotted edges and my polymer now
wouldn't be separate polymers it would
be all one big polymer
um and and and then we can have our
weight function which involves the
number of connected components and
e to the beta minus one uh to the minus
number of
actual solid red edges uh but this is
this
this and expansion uh some arguments is
actually what we're doing
to uh understand this non-local
interaction
okay so the consequence is what happens
um so
we get convergent cluster expansions so
we get that the disordered
cluster expansion converges in a range
like that
and the ordered cluster expansion
converges in a range like this
luckily for us they're overlapping and
so we can control things at all
temperatures
this gives us algorithms at all
temperatures and convergent cluster
expansions
essentially tell you anything
probabilistic you would ever want to
know exponential decay of correlations
large deviation bounds central limit
theorems
and so on um and then and then we also
connect this with an infinite tree
uh in some way but that
that that's basically the idea uh of
course these techniques
uh this is how they understand or they
did understand
lattice spin models but i i haven't seen
this applied to
random graphs uh yeah uh okay so i
wanted to end
uh last couple minutes with a couple of
open questions some i think maybe
uh maybe people could answer right away
i you know with the pandemic i haven't
really chatted about this to
lots of people so maybe you guys can
answer it right away so we know that the
critical
value for pots on uh for pots
is given by this formula uh there's no
reason in the world that this shouldn't
extend to random cluster
but we don't know how to do it and and
you know we have some connection with
the tree
and we can understand the disordered
free energy we have a formula for that
on the tree or or in the random graph
but the ordered
case is like some strange power series
um another thing would be we have this d
greater than five condition but somehow
if we have a little bit more refined
definition of the ordered polymers
maybe you can uh do all d
uh i would i'd be very interested at
least to know what does a cavity method
or what does a second moment method
can you apply this to random cluster
even though it's uh has this non-local
interaction
um you know maybe it maybe as a way to
prove
this first conjecture um
another problem i like is hardcore on
random regular bipartite graphs
we have algorithms when lambda is large
enough
um but i don't think there's any reason
why you shouldn't have efficient
algorithms for all
lambda but you don't have this nice uh
this approach won't work all the way
down to the critical lambda
and then finally uh you know the in
terms of understanding pots model on zd
there's lots of modern techniques that
don't require large q
and i would be very interested if those
techniques could be
turned into into algorithms so if we
understand something very well
probabilistically
can you also always sample and count
efficiently
okay that's it thank you
thank you for a very nice talk questions
i have a question so will the the top
open question here the issue is that
when q is not an integer
is that the issue exactly yeah so this
holds for integers
because uh the pots and random cluster
phase transition have to be at the same
point
right but for non-integer i don't know
i i remember having my mind blown in
grad school when i read that random
spanning trees are like the
pots model with zero states right
um but the my other question so you say
that the
um the ordered and disordered states
which are kind of intuitively high in
low temperature or sorry low and high
temperature states
the the convergence the range of
temperatures at which they converge
overlap so just saying this out loud
you're saying that perturbations from
a completely disordered state
are still pretty good a little bit above
the critical beta where the typical
states are ordered
and vice versa that perturbations from
an ordered state are still
a reasonable approximation a little bit
below
the critical beta even though typical
states are disordered
and this is this is sort of hard to
this is sort of hard to imagine i mean i
would really expect both of these
to stop at the critical point well
you're putting like some very strong
restriction on so the the way you define
the ordered and disordered is say
these configurations have less than 10
or greater than 10
or greater than 90 percent of edges um
but you know like what happens in the
pots model if you look at the second
moment calculation there's a local max
uh at for the disordered state um
even past beta critical uh and so if you
started
your your global dynamics there
you would you would get stuck i guess
um yeah i mean
i mean it's interesting to think about
the zd case as well so the same thing is
true
but that what's true is like some
truncated in some truncated model
and so you don't actually you don't
actually see
uh yeah i mean there's there's no
contradiction i think to saying there's
a
convergent cluster expansion and you
only see one or the other
so you're saying there's a sort of phase
coexistence in an open interval of beta
but not not in the physical sense but in
the kind of mathematical sense
yeah i guess i guess that's right
why isn't it because just you are
restricting the partition functions
to the subset of clusters configuration
that have very few
very little charges right so yeah that's
exactly
each of the two is analytic across the
critical point
but the max of the two is not analytical
yeah
exactly so the critical point is just to
find it when these restricted free
energies are equal
that's the definition of the critical
point so i would like to perhaps have a
question
you know can you explain a little bit so
since you have uh i guess since you have
this expansion you can also prove that
you know basically whatever local
quantities you compute on the graph
are you know as you as you said they
converge to the
you know whatever you would have on the
tree with wire
or or or not boundary
and now on the tree you can do a cavity
calculation for any queue
with acquired or not wired calculation
right i mean
that that's just a recursive thing right
i mean but even i mean so i looked there
was some like old paper that tried that
did
a cavity computation with random cluster
model
it's different than the cavity
computation i know because uh
you have this non-local thing this
keyboard right right but you have a
little bit i think i don't remember if
somebody
probably did it but you have to be a
little bit careful about what you define
the state of the root right
that is is it connected i think that the
state of the root is
is it connected to the boundary or not
and then you do a recursion you define a
partial partition function
you know conditional you know you define
a partition function on the three
by saying okay some overall cluster
configuration on three
that have the root connected to the
boundary or root not connected to the
boundary
and then so you have two functions z
zero and z one and you write a recursion
for those
something you know i wasn't i wasn't
clear if
that was enough information it's
probably in some paper that
yeah but certainly if you could solve
that the tree problem you would solve
the
this conjecture because i think we make
a strict connection between the two
yeah yeah yeah i mean you have a lot of
information
other questions uh
will on the on the hardcore model uh
just trying to recapture the state of
the art uh
for i i thought you you showed that for
large enough lambda
this is true for bipartite graphs which
are expanded right not necessarily
definitely
right that's right that's right so
actually the algorithms here
just need some expansion conditions as
well they don't need to be random graphs
okay expansion is all you need yeah
so we here we use like two expansion
conditions one like the usual expansion
and one like some small set expansion
condition at one point
but yeah that's it
um so so it does mean that the algorithm
already works for hardcore on random
say random regular graphs it doesn't
have to be to be bipartite right
no no no it certainly has to be
bipartite because we're uh
we're perturbing around the ground
states and the ground states for
bipartite are just even odd
for yeah yeah i'm not i don't know
anything about how to find independent
sets in non-bipartite graphs
and is it known to have any sampling
algorithm for
for random regular graphs it's known up
to this white's threshold the uniqueness
threshold now
but after that it's not known
no it's i i think we for large enough
lambda
we know it's not mixing on the random
regular graph non-bipartisan it's not
going to be
mixing oh it is not for very large
lambda but we don't know where it stops
mixing fast
okay i see
all right yeah because they cost this
yeah
more questions
so perhaps you can tell us when you the
last line
make other probabilistic techniques
algorithmic
is what is your next objective
well i i would like to you know these
papers by duminell kopan where that
where he
proves like the first order phase
transition for pots
on zd uh really in the optimal range
i would like to understand i don't know
those papers i would like to understand
read those and see can those be made
algorithmic
well maybe i'll ask a question that i
asked two hours ago because i
i actually didn't really get it um in
the slides it was
quite quick of what the polymer was was
defined so i couldn't really see the
link between the
polymers and the cluster model
are they the terms just defined in the
in the cluster model or are they the
terms that appear in the
taylor expansion of the log of that yeah
so this this is what i was worried about
the
the
the cluster in the random cluster has
nothing to do with cluster and the
cluster expansion
um but um
[Music]
these polymers are i just want to like
say like look i have a
a a nearly empty uh
configuration of edges and i have a few
sprinkled edges
how do i like separate these into nice
objects i'm just going to separate them
into
their connected components and i'm going
to treat each of these almost like a
spin
in some auxiliary spin model
that's that's a better you can place the
model right
random cluster model is just a probably
distribution over edges
i mean you're right the the the clusters
the queue to the number of connected
components
is like this that's right um but the
definition it's it's
you know yeah so there's they're
separate but somehow
like like what's what's really the link
how how are polymers
linked to to the subject that you are
studying
maybe that was the point that i lost in
in the talk
it it gives us a way to write a
convergent power series for the log
partition function
it's a way to analyze they they appear
in the taylor expansion of blocks that
is correct
so aren't the polymers that you what you
call the polymer just the connected
components of of
the cluster model uh in in the disorder
case
yes except that we have some upper bound
we have some upper bound on the size
because we don't want to flip to the
other state
yeah and on the other you construct this
boundary
and yeah it's more complicated yeah
okay so if there is no more question
perhaps we can take a real five minutes
break
thanks will again for a great talk thank
you